warframe has grown from a modest
free-to-play experiment that was very
much a work in progress to an impressive
online game with an ever-growing fan
base since its launch in 2013 the action
RPG starring space ninjas slashing and
shooting across the universe has evolved
in a big way after its many expansions
giving players more ways to customize
their characters and team up in
different scenarios to take on the
toughest challenges in the game not long
after the release of fortuna the largest
expansion to date the developers of
digital Xtreme and along with switchport
veterans panic button games will launch
their most ambitious project to date a
port of the massive game to the Nintendo
switch we recently tried out the newest
version of warframe prior to its launch
and came away pleased with how faithful
it was to the previous versions of the
game
set for release on November 20th
warframe brings its fast-paced and
kinetic game played in Nintendo's
platform marking the first time the game
will be playable in portable format
diving into warfare him for the first
time can be daunting but once you get
into the swing of it you'll find a game
that offers a lot of variety and systems
to dive into showing similar shades to
the power grind and gameplay found in
destiny as one of the switches few
online only games putting in the same
company as the immensely popular
fortnight warframe is a games as a
service title with its own unique online
infrastructure and won't require players
to have access to in a Nintendo online
at launch the switch version will offer
14 different planets to travel to over
200 different melee weapons and firearms
to collect more than 30 unique
characters to level up and master and a
detailed plot showing the escalating war
among the different factions vying for
control in collaboration with panic
button games the same studio behind the
impressive switch ports for doom 2016
and Wolfenstein 2 the new Colossus the
two developers worked extensively to
make sure that the next port of the game
could stand up alongside the others if
you're familiar with the feel and play
style the ps4 and Xbox one editions of
warframe then you'll be able to pick up
the game quite easily
however some clear concessions were made
to ensure that the game was in stable
shape for the portable hardware running
out of mostly stable 30 frames per
second and at 720p and both docked and
undocked States warframe on switch will
likely take some adjusting to four
players who've invested many hours in
other versions which were uncomfortably
at 60fps moreover there's some
occasional dips in framerate during the
more intense encounters particularly
when multiple players use their powers
and weapons simultaneously while the
developers acknowledge the technical
changes between the different releases
they stated that the primary focus was
to keep the action smooth and the
framerate stable
for the most part the switch version
does a solid job of keeping up with the
gameplay while also highlighting the
strengths of the console swapping
between docked and undocked modes is
simple and painless and there isn't much
difference in performance between the
two which is great when you want to
bundle up with the game in handheld mode
after playing in docked the switch
version also features motion control
functionality letting you perform some
actions with the motion of your wrist
such as fishing shooting your firearms
and using other tools in game the switch
release also features integrated voice
chat allowing party members to
communicate with each other without the
need of the Nintendo app if you're a
seasoned player then you can also import
your account from the PC over to the
switch unfortunately the switch version
will not offer cross play opting to
stick with its own player base in
ecosystem when you really look at it
there's really no other game on the
switch like warframe though it's been
often seen as the destiny before destiny
it certainly goes out of its way to
offer up options and different
adventures for players to dive into it's
one of those games that's gotten better
with age and with the amount of content
that's still on the way warfare months
which will be a solid entry point for
those looking for a sizable game to dive
into which has kept its unique sense of
style and flow very much attacked on the
new platform